hey Rachel how you doing I'm good how
are you good what do you got for me
tonight
um
I don't have anything in particular in
mind but I'm familiar
oh all right and I've noticed that
you've been bringing on girls lately so
um a lot of them tend to be like girls
who are like kind of more in their boss
babe or whatever they might call it but
um I think that
they come to you for advice on how to
find like a high value man but if
they're listening and they're watching I
want to give them some of my advice okay
you want to give some advice to the boss
girls that are watching yeah yeah all
right let's see let's see what you got
go ahead
Okay so
find a high value
there's no like fun
high value man finding to me is like
kind of pursuing and the fact that
they're like pursuing a high value man
doesn't really make a lot of sense they
can find you and they think that if they
if even if they did listen to the things
let me just let me just challenge you on
that for a second because I've said this
for a few years now like
I don't think top shelf men that these
women Pine for the usually the kind of
guys that they're describing right got
to be tall got to be confident got to be
able to make it rain gotta be funny got
to be humble you know the list
um they're generally not out there I
think chasing women I think what they're
doing is they're is they're on a purpose
they're on a grind and they're putting a
dent in the universe and maybe as they
go about their day they're running into
people like hey Rich let me introduce
you my friend uh I think you know you
guys get along well blah blah blah
that's usually how I see that going down
I don't see a lot of top shelf men
chasing women that's why I always
encourage women to make the effort
I mean that's true but
um let me ask you this do you feel like
if the woman that you brought on that
have those struggles like if they were
to listen to your advice do you think
that they would like actually find one
and like be happy with one because
they're always chasing Excellence right
so yeah
secondary to their life and they they
may not be used to that unfortunately it
seems like it it tends to fall on deaf
ears you know for the most part like
they understand but it also seems like
whenever the cop The Conversation Piece
comes up the question comes up
then it always defaults to well if I
don't find anybody then it's totally
fine I'll be I'll be happy you know by
myself and that's fine to say that when
you're like 30 or 31 or 32 and you might
think you've got a lot of Runway but
time moves really fast one of the things
I've noticed as I've gotten older is
like your teen years and your 20s seem
to move pretty slow by the time you get
in your 30s and 40s time starts to move
a lot faster for some reason and it's
like you know before you know you're
like I'm 60 or whatever right how
old are you right now
124. and what's your experience been
like dating like what are you finding
out there
um
well I'm not really finding anything
experience
um I recently um dated a guy who's
familiar with your show and he has your
book oh okay how did that go
uh you were actually a talking point on
our first date because I was just kind
of talking
things that
um I believe and things like that and he
was like you kind of sound like someone
that I watch his name is Richard Cooper
like are you familiar and I was like I
think I've seen a couple videos because
I've seen the videos where you're like
the green flags and the red flags right
and then so we have talked about
University which is kind of crazy but
um and that was something I never
thought when I was doing this YouTube
stuff that I would be the conversation
piece for a first date but this is this
is kind of cool but yeah
um so anyways
um
yeah so my point was is that um he he
was always chasing excellent he's a
great man I have nothing but say about
him but but one thing that I wasn't used
to was it wasn't used to being like he
was always chasing his own thing and
it's always like being secondary and
usually when a man's chasing Excellence
Excellence all the time like you say
it's like it's not something that you're
really used to and I feel like a lot of
women don't may not realize like like
what it really is like to be with like a
man of high status and it takes a lot to
get to where where they are and so what
I was saying was they come to you asking
like kind of how do they get that it's
like well how do you know you even
really want that as well like it's it's
not always easy to be with like a high
value man so what did this guy do for a
living
um he is like a higher up for like an
energy
um distribution center and then he has
side business aside DJ business and then
he has um properties as well
I am well chuffed that somebody that
caliber watches my stuff and even had
the balls to mention it to you on a date
because I would generally not recommend
talking to a date about my stuff and be
like hey do you watch Rich Cooper have
you seen this stuff because it's
probably it's probably not going to go
that way but I guess the good part of it
is that it's going to weed out anybody
that is vehemently opposed to anything
that I say so you guys got along good
did you get a second date oh no yeah we
saw each other for about six months yeah
but it's uh but it wrapped up it ran its
course so what happened yeah it ran its
course
um I have nothing but good things to say
about him but it was kind of like my
point though of just like I kind of felt
like secondary to his life and I kind of
felt like in the moment he had just
started his business the same time his
second business the same that we met and
it was kind of hard to like fit
everything between and I was moving at
the time and I was just like I think I
just need to just like be alone for now
and we we talk now we're on great terms
I have nothing but a good thing to say
about him I just don't think I was
really cut out for it at the time
um did you did you have an issue coming
second to him and his purpose
because I noticed that some women
struggle with that
um
maybe a little bit I was always really
supportive and I did believe in his
vision like he he is successful in the
things that he does but yeah I mean yeah
not trouble supporting it but maybe just
like trouble feeling like seen and like
feeling like I had like a present
partner if that makes sense
so so were you seen or or were you not
seen in a way that was comfortable for
you
I mean
so like like I was an important part of
his life but he would say that
um but it was I don't know maybe we just
had different Like Love Languages or
something like that it was just hard for
me to feel like I was of importance I
don't I really don't know so it was for
me it was harder to like bond with him
because I felt like every time that we
talked he would talk about all of his
things that he had going on in like ABC
and d and I was always interested but it
just it was hard but then it would be
like okay so what about you but I'm not
doing all of those things right so it
was kind of like an imbalance there yeah
so the so the whole love language thing
has been debunked it doesn't
it's not a thing
um are you okay with coming behind a
man's purpose in life because I mean if
you want to be with a top shelf guy
and like what's your goal you're looking
to have a family are you looking to
climb the corporate ladder like what are
you trying to do definitely not climb
the corporate ladder I definitely want
to see
um but yeah that's something that I've
been asking myself rich is just like
it's like okay I had that and he's a
great man and I didn't feel like like it
was where I was needed to be like I just
don't I I'm unsure I'm really unsure
because I don't I don't want to fall
into that that corporate ladder and I
and I definitely want a family that's
like my top priority and I really had to
sit back and think about like what it is
that I want but well if you're thinking
about this now in your 20s that's really
good because like I said time does move
fast and you like you're one year Beauty
and your fertility is obviously
perishable and it's a lot more
perishable for women than it is for men
unfortunately that's not I'm not
misogynistic by saying that that's just
a fact of Science and biology and I
think you understand that which is which
is good because we don't need to argue
about that but
coming coming into a dude's life
supporting his mission entering his
frame being a compliment let you know
letting it be known and clear that the
reason why you're there is because you
dig as Vibe and you're looking to start
a family that's that's the correct path
to go down how you two figure that out
how you structure it
I'm I'm not imposing you know beliefs on
anybody I'm just offering experiences
and ideas with the stuff that I talk
about so when I say things like I'm not
a big fan of marriage don't get married
get married doesn't matter to me I'm
more talking to guys though it's like
look you know if you're a smart guy
don't do it in such a way where it could
potentially cause risk and pay attention
to what she's about size her up see what
her red flags are like so guys that are
watching my stuff and it's interesting
that it's getting to the point now where
it's it's coming up on a conversation on
a date hey hi Rachel you know there's
this guy Rich Cooper and you sound a lot
like his stuff and you know you start to
connect with it that's actually a pretty
good thing and believe it or not I think
that it facilitates far better
relationships when men can be in their
masculine and they can pursue Excellence
put a dent in the universe and be
admired by a feminine beauty that enters
his frame and is a compliment to it and
men and women are better together than
they are apart right it's just the guy
needs to know how to lead and set proper
boundaries and a 1 it has to be okay
with following that lead in those
boundaries absolutely I agree right so
you don't really have anything to
challenge me on did you have any other
questions because I got a bunch of
people waiting to hop on no no I didn't
have anything to challenge you on I just
kind of just did it so all right well if
you ever have anything in the future
feel free to call back in okay thank you
Rich have a good night Rachel ciao I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out